the final season of Game of Thrones is
here and there's a lot to remember from
the last 67 episodes
who's fighting who who's related to who
and who's having sex even though they're
related what's going on in Game of
Thrones Season age basically Jon Snow
and Daenerys and almost every other
character are united against the White
Walkers and their army of the Dead but
in the south Cersei Lannister has the
throne she said she'd help the good guys
but she lied and she's got your on
bringing her an army to help her hold
power Circe's brother lover Jaime has
left her to help fight the dead
Theon is trying to rescue his sister
Yara from their uncle Euron Melisandre
is off in the east and hot pies kickin
it in the Riverlands so how'd everyone
get here what are their motivations
conflicts and relationships Jon Snow who
was a misfit bastard at Winterfell
he joined the Nights Watch and became a
heroic and principled leader he's made
sacrifices for the greater good giving
up his love and his pride and his life
now he's king in the north
and he's sworn to serve Daenerys and
they're ready to fight the White Walkers
together but John and Narus are in love
which will get awkward because they're
about to find out that Daenerys is
John's aren't and that John is the
rightful king ahead of her
how will John balance love and duty and
what more will John have to sacrifice to
save the world John's sister Sansa helps
him rule Winterfell but there is tension
because they don't agree on all of his
decisions John's favorite sister was
always I and soon they'll finally
reunite John is close friends with Sam
and Edie he's friendly with Tyrion and
divorces his advisor John also has a
special Duggar called ghost who we
almost never see because he's tricky to
film
Melisandre said that John is the prince
that was promised a hero prophesied to
defeat the darkness with a flaming sword
she also said that Daenerys has a role
to play which the prophecy suggests
might involve sacrifice Daenerys
Targaryen was a meek abused girl till
she embraced the power of the Daath
rocki than the magic of a Targaryen
blood she got three dragons conquered
slavers Bay and learned to be a clean
balancing piece and compromised against
violence and fire Daenerys has
compassion for the weak
she liber8 sons of slaves and now she
wants to claim the throne of Westeros
and to build a better world but how can
she win her war without killing
thousands and becoming a tyrant like her
father her war is further complicated by
the zombie apocalypse and by her hot
nephew Daenerys keeps saying that she
can't have children
which probably means that she'll have a
baby with John Daenerys is closest
friends and advisors Armas and I and
Jorah aka sir friendzone she also has
tyrion and varys who she doesn't
entirely trust Daenerys has an army of
unsullied and Dothraki but only two
dragons now because one of them was
taken by the white walkers Daenerys has
wanted to rule Westeros for seven
seasons now but will she ever win the
throne in a vision in season two she
reaches for the throne but never takes
it Cersei Lannister was always
frustrated at trying to be a powerful
woman in a patriarchal world she was
married to a drunk violent idiot when
her true love was a twin brother Jaime
Cersei learned to be ruthless and
manipulative to protect her children and
her power
Cersei hates her brother Tyrion
especially once he murders their father
Tywin Circe's jealousy and paranoia
brings about her downfall
so she strikes back with fiery vengeance
killing hundreds of innocents torturing
her enemies and taking the throne all
her children are dead now and her lover
Jaime is gone
so while Cersei has left is the throne
and a grief and her hate and her unborn
child euron greyjoy
is bringing her an army and she's got
the mad scientist Qyburn and the murder
zombie mountain can Cersei hold the
throne or will she self-destruct there's
a prophecy that Cersei will be cast down
by someone younger and more beautiful
which could be Daenerys or maybe Sansa
or even Bri
in the books the prophecy says that
Cersei will be killed by her brother so
she might be killed by Jaime or maybe by
iya wearing Jaime's face Jaime Lannister
began as an arrogant violent villain he
pushed bran from a window to hide his
incest with Cersei and he attacked Ned
Stark
but then Jaime got captured and lost his
sword hand and Brienne taught him honor
and humility we learned Jaime's
backstory that he killed his King to
save a city but was hated for breaking
his oaths Jaime wants to redeem himself
achieve deeds worthy of the white book
so he sent Brienne to help Sansa and
Arya and tried to save his daughter miss
Ella
and finally Jaime has left his lifelong
lover Cersei and rides north to help
fight the white walkers that Jaime might
not be very welcome at Winterfell
because Jaime crippled bran and ward
against the Starks and killed Daenerys
as father the Mad King his relationship
with Tyrion is also difficult since
Tyrion killed their father
Jaime said he wants to die in the arms
of the woman he loves so will he die
with Cersei or is Brienne his true love
Tyrion Lannister always felt unloved and
unappreciated using his wits and wealth
to protect himself he found love with
Shae and enjoyed having power in King's
Landing but the hatred of his father
Tywin and of Cersei and Joffrey led him
to kill his father and his lover Tyrion
was depressed and hopeless until he met
Daenerys Tyrion believes in Daenerys and
her dream of a better world but Daenerys
wages war against here Ian's family so
Tyrians loyalties are torn Tyrion is
friendly with John and with Varys he's
mates with bran and Podrick he was
briefly in an arranged marriage to Sansa
and they seem to respect each other
still but his brother Jaime is still mad
that Tyrion killed their dad and his
sister Cersei despises him
Tyrion desperately wants peace with his
siblings because if Tyrians family
doesn't love him
who will Sansa Stark once dreamed of
being a queen and marrying a handsome
prints but she was soon disillusioned
she became a political pawn beaten and
abused by Joffrey than Ramsay but
gradually Sansa learned politics from
some of the most devious players in the
game like Littlefinger Elena and Cersei
Sansa helped take back Winterfell and
enjoys having political power so how
will she react when Daenerys and John
threaten that power Sansa is friends
with our sister aya after a shaky
reunion last season and Brienne is sworn
to serve and protect her Sansa will soon
reunite with her ex-husband
Tyrion and with the Hound who was kind
to her at the capital aya stark was a
tomboy who didn't fit in the role of a
noble lady she got separated from her
family and her identity and so terrible
suffering and injustice her mentors were
killers age more deadly than the last
Syrio Forel the hound and Jachin Agha
the faceless men trained her to fight
and to wear faces as magical disguises
that she rejected their religion and
returned to her identity as a stark
iowans revenge on the people who hurt
her family and Cersei and the mountain
are on her list she'll also help find
the White Walkers and the dead but the
more i akil's for anger and hate the
more she's separated from her family
she's become distant and suspicious and
threatened to kill her sister can I
offend peace and love or only blood and
death she will finally reunite with Jon
and probably with the hound and Gendry
Gendry liked to call aya milady
they could have a relationship but ayah
is fiercely independent
she said she'd like to go explore the
world I as direwolf Nymeria is still out
there leading a wolf pack maybe they'll
help in the battles to come
bran Stark he used to be a happy kid who
dreamed of being a knight until Jamie
pushed him from a tower crippling him
Jojen Meera and Hodor journeyed with
bran to the three-eyed raven who taught
him to have visions of future and past
and - warg into the minds of
the creatures but power came at a cost
Jojen and Hodor and the direwolf summer
all died and bran damaged Hodor through
some timey wimey stuff bran became the
new three-eyed Raven and kind of lost
his personality he's become robotic and
cold disconnected from his sisters Sansa
and aya his powers will be important in
the war against the White Walkers
he might warg into a dragon or have an
important vision or have a psychic
battle with the night king there are
theories about bran being the night king
in some kind of time loop which might be
cool or dumb but will bran ever be bran
again bran has no memory of his fall but
Jaime is returning to Winterfell maybe
seeing the man who pushed him we'll
remind bran of the boy he used to be
Theon Greyjoy just wanted to belong he
never fit in as a Greyjoy at Winterfell
so he betrayed the Starks attacked the
family that raised him and killed
innocent kids he was captured by Ramsay
who tortured him castrated him and took
away his very identity but then Theon
helped Sansa escape Winterfell and
joined Daenerys with his sister Yara
Theon is still traumatized but he now
hopes to face his fears and to rescue
Yara from their uncle Euron just as Yara
once tried to rescue him
Theon says that his crimes are beyond
forgiveness but what is dead can never
die and Theon might still have the
strength to do some good Yara is a
warrior and a leader he wants to be the
first queen of the Iron Islands as for
Euron he's a scary
eldritch pirate in the books but in the
show he mostly just wants to wear
leather and pork Cersei Brienne
struggled to find a place for herself in
a world that didn't accept female
warriors she felt that she failed King
Renly and failed Catelyn Stark
but then Brienne avenged Renly and
helped protect Caitlyn's daughters Sansa
and Arya Brienne has finally found
success and respect and now more than
ever
Brienne knows who she is now she joins
the fight against the White Walkers
Brienne almost killed the Hound one time
they're cool and tormund has a giant
crush on her but her closest bond is
with Jamie
they taught each other to be better
versions of themselves will they become
lovers or die together or just remain
close friends Brienne's loyal Squire
Podrick has been training at combat
maybe he'll do something heroic and
finally be made a knight also pod Foxx
Jorah was exiled from Westeros for
selling slaves shamed and disillusioned
he originally spied on Daenerys and
almost got her killed
but seeing Denny's power and her dragons
inspired Jorah he became totally loyal
and in love with Daenerys she did exile
him a couple times for his earlier
betrayal and for his gross skin
condition but now Joris loyalty is
unquestioned he's even accepted that
Danny loves John not him Jorah is
willing to die for Dany and he probably
will Jorah is grateful to Sam for curing
his greyscale and Jorah now wields Sam's
family Valyrian sword also Lyanna
Mormont is Joris niece she might not be
happy with her deadbeat uncle coming
home Sam tally was a misfit and a coward
rejected by his father but John helped
him find a place at the Nights Watch and
eventually to study at the Citadel Sam
found the courage to kill a white Walker
and to stand up to his dad Gilly grew up
in the cruelty of Craster's cape sam was
the first to trader with kindness and
helped gillyflower into a bright more
confident woman they found unlikely love
in one another and Sam adopted Gilley's
baby as his own though that baby was
originally promised to the White Walkers
and the walkers might want him back as
John's closest friend Sam plans to break
the news that jon is heir to the throne
and is the nephew to his girlfriend the
red woman Melisandre is a priestess to
the Lord of Light
she once believed that Stannis would
save the world and she did all sorts of
[ __ ] up magic for him but then Stannis
died
throwing MIL into doubt and depression
we saw her Adam
vulnerable it turns out that Melisandre
is ancient and uses magic to hide it but
then Melisandre resurrected Jon Snow
restoring her faith she now believes
that Jon and Daenerys are the chosen
ones
she has gone east to volantis maybe to
bring help from other red priests
Melisandre said that shield returned to
Westeros and died there John and Davos
have both promised to kill Melisandre if
she returns because Melbourne Shireen so
maybe Mel will die as she lived with
fire magic and blood also Melisandre
once met Arya and said that she'd see
her again Varys grew up on the streets
and his [ __ ] and balls were cut off by a
wizard so he's not a big fan of magic or
people who use it like Melisandre Varys
was spymaster for King Robert but he
secretly supported the Targaryen Varys
wants a ruler who will protect the
people and he believes that Daenerys is
the best hope for peace
but he has said that he'll stop
supporting Dany if she stops being a
good Queen and Daenerys promised to burn
him if he betrays her Melisandre said
that Varys will die in Westeros when the
Hound was a boy his brother the mountain
burned his face scarring him for life
and giving him a fear of fire The Hound
feels betrayed and alone and he hides
this with violence and hate the Hound
found a kindred spirit in aya then he
was almost killed by Brienne the Hound
returned and was offered a chance at
redemption to do some good in the world
berrak and Thoris tell him that the Lord
of Light has a plan for them all The
Hound starts to show some compassion and
he helps the heroes fight beyond the
wall but the Hound has unfinished
business with the mountain maybe he'll
overcome his fear of fire to kill his
brother and put his demons to rest grey
worm and missandei were slaves
dehumanized and abused until Daenerys
won their freedom and their loyalty grey
worm leads Danny's unsullied and
missandei is her closest advisor
gradually they've learned to leave
and love freely despite the trauma of
their past but loving means having
something to lose maybe grey worm or
missandei who'll die next season bran
was once an opportunistic killer now
he's a rich opportunistic killer
thanks to Tyrion and Jaime but after
everything he's done for the Lannisters
bran wants a bigger reward he wants a
castle
Cersei did give him one once but then
she took it back off him
and now Tyrion has asked Bronn to join
him again Tyrion says that he'll pay
double so one cool theory is that bran
will get the twins the two Frey castles
linked across a river
the twins are conveniently vacant since
iock ill the phrase last season so maybe
bran of all people will get his happily
ever after beric Dondarrion believes
that he has a special destiny for the
Lord of Light he's been killed then
resurrected six times but now that his
priests Thoris is dead barracks on his
last life tormund fights for the
survival of his people the wildlings he
also hopes to win the heart of his
beloved Brienne Davos was a smuggler a
common man who rose to be advisor to
Stannis and then to John he's
consistently a voice of reason
telling leaders to do the right thing
not the easy thing he's no nonsense and
no drama
he barely ever mentions that Tyrion blew
up his son however he is furious at
Melisandre for killing Shireen and he's
also very fond of Gendry Gendry is the
bastard son of King Robert he's a
blacksmith and he can swing a hammer
real good he's got a decent rowing form
excellent cardio and possibly a crush on
iya he'll be forging special weapons to
fight the White Walkers and the dead the
White Walkers are a mysterious looming
threat an ancient force of winter and
darkness they were originally created by
the children of the forest to defend the
children from humans but the walkers
apparently got out of control and now
threaten all life the walkers can raise
the dead as mindless zombies called why
the walkers can be killed with
dragonglass or Valyrian steel and the
whites can be killed with fire glass
steel or basically anything
the walkers and whites are led by the
knight King the first white Walker it
also seems connected to magic like bran
we don't know exactly what the White
Walkers want we know they turn human
babies into more white walkers and make
symbols out of corpses so there might be
more to learn about the walkers before
the end the white walkers have taken one
of Daenerys dragons and have at least a
hundred thousand dead soldiers they seem
unstoppable but beric reckons that if
the knight king is killed all the
walkers and whites will fall there are
connections between the white walkers
and the Starks go watch this video
finally hot pie has been chillin and
killin since season 1 it survived
Harrenhal and the Brotherhood and his
baking has only gotten better hot pies a
survivor and he'll probably outlive the
rest so that's where everyone's at at
the beginning of the end of Game of
Thrones we're holding a live stream
right after each episode of season 8 at
about 10 p.m. Eastern Time and we're
making breakdown videos each week so
subscribe and press the bell the patreon
supporters can watch past live streams
and get extra updates we also got much
t-shirts and pins thanks to patrons
Jenny Lake Marcus Chiodo ma M fisher
casey whitney hutchinson p man foggers
bell singh mehmet sensor karadayi
Claudia and schlocky Cheers
you